[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we've new wheels a pre celebration for
the big day huh I'm making partner baby
ceiling
[Music]
worldwide sports management newest
partner boys club every days you don't
connect well with men just stay in your
lane I don't trust women who don't get
dudes like I don't trust a man with no
eyebrows are too many keys I know
someone you should talk to I can help
you commit with me why don't we have
some tea this is like dirt oh that's
just jasmine tea if you don't count the
weed no peyote no Kirk
[Applause]
oh hello welcome back miss Davis
thank God this one didn't die on me
starting today no more drinking at work
hey that's too much information that's
anything I feel we here after last night
yeah that's what happens when tequila
meets and desperation okay stop saying
things you shouldn't be saying to your
boss
holy crap can you hear my inner thoughts
I can only move stuff that cloud you're
walking through that's my farts I
thought black people stopped running th
Oh get out
where would you complain about men
trying to keep you down do we have any
meetings on the books nothing yet except
the private poker game tonight this is
not a curse Asha tete-a-tete
the lady which is doing it the big boys
table huh - quiet I'm bluffing these
fools I'm missing Real Housewives check
finally has a winning hand
why am I thinking in the third person I
smell toast my happiness throw weight I
have chosen my pocket
[Music]
you